quant à 31 ans et tu as dit le 13ème
porte chance est ce que c'est pour faire
plaisir à lelouch
non ça fait très longtemps que
13ème à la chance parce que j'ai 13
lettres à mon nom mais j'habitais dans
une rue g t au numéro 13 quand on était
petit et surtout mégane rs je remarque
qu'à chaque fois 13 sociétés pour
rencontrer alors
je sais qu'on système nommé dit un jour
à 13 est un tournoi avec lelouch ray et
quand on me dit quelque chose comme ça
j'ai tendance à fort symbole d'histoire
en tous les cas tu es limbé et treize
personnages de son 31ème film qui a été
tourné en 31 jours pour les films 13
voix la tendance ça s'est bien passé
est ce que tu es content du trait ouais
c'est un très très bon très millions et
c'est des petites choses de la vie et
c'est dans la vie quand je suis avec un
ami et qu'on rigole etc
à des fous rires on déconne on dire car
le louche il fait ça il nous prend à des
moments où
m urs nature alors toi c'est vraiment
parce que tu as joué un flic dans un
film c'était lui faut qu'on t'a jouer
l'inspecteur de police dans un film
disserter parole de flic et gendarmes
dont 37 2 points et a dit d'ailleurs une
fois j'aurais pu être unique
j'aurais adoré et oratoires et ouais
alors à cause de ça on va faire une
interview qui s'appelle la sphère
musicale monde est d'accord stade et
surnom n'ont jamais d'abord non non non
la main on n'a plus un sou les lorrains
emilio étape et comment tu t'appelles
j'ai pas de tp d'abord et en plus elles
n'ont marceau vincent revenais pas
taille 1 79 le poids comme ça le poids
80 canoë cas de 80 81 79 attaquer quand
même les dents ça va et donc ça se passe
bien les yeux les yeux pas mal je vends
des lunettes pour voir de loin les
signes particuliers tu te ronge les
ongles il paraît je me ronge les ongles
et génétique mais t on pas très bien au
départ
ouais maison que tu arrives pas
d'arrêter quoi j'essaye temps en temps
je les laisse pousser et après que je
l'état tu es donc ça se casse et gelé
quand j'en ai rangé un jour j'ai dit ce
mois-ci ou tout bien oui eh ouais et
l'éthique alors fait quoi faire les dix
que sais je sais pas je sais tout et
d'abord depuis tout petit je n'ai
absolument aucun problème
ça m'a complètement légale et les gens
généralement oublié au bout d'un long
j'aurais et quand je tourne à partir du
moment où d'une hauteur je louche
il dit qu'il voulait que telle éthique
pendant le film et que dès que la caméra
détecte entendez le clat savait plus
très bons donc été pour faire du cinéma
et je fais pas exprès c'est automatique
pendant que c'est jérôme lindon des
éditions de minuit et on perd il faisait
quoi il a une affaire de l'autoradio
pour voitures ces bourgeois quand même
oui et toi tu as dit j'aime le peuple a
dit ils disent je vais au coiffeur mais
ils ont du coeur c'est très attiré par
le populo ouais ouais ouais
jeanne public j'aime le peuple j'ai mal
au stade et c'est pas du tout en
réaction contre la famille ça n'a rien à
voir et et j'ai des jeux je trouve que
si on n'a pas choisi de naître
on ne peut rien donc les acteurs ont
tendance à trouver ça bien d'arriver de
rien et d'avoir franchi la banlieue et
puis arrive à paris ben non moi je n'y
peux rien je suis avec ma mère j'ai
alors candidat parfois je suis très
content parce que je fais très à l'aise
dans les bistrots les trucs le train
contre 1,13 et a dit le ciné c'est
facile parce que on peut devenir tous
vivent deux mois pour ça qu'on n'était
pas vraiment envie de te faire chef de
l'irs toubib non c'est moi ce que j'aime
dans le cinéma j'aime j'aime beaucoup
aussi
j'aime le peuple j'aime les films
populaires et j'aime faire des
j'aimerais faire des cascades des parce
que je trouve que c'est bien
faire aussi des masques ou pas faire
dans la vie c'est à dire sûreté
l'hélicoptère rentrer dans un bar avec
un pistolet et faire maintenant tout le
monde à terre bon ok tout ce qui est les
films on se prend un petit peu
au sérieux on se prend la tête on
s'ouvre les veines c'est bien mais
j'aime bien faire des choses qu'on peut
alors tu as fait l'armée non t'as pas
fait l'armée non pourquoi
ex ante haut et pourquoi parce que déjà
le parvis de la faire et parce que j'ai
je sais pas je fais quand même comment
on fait tous j'ai fait croire qu'elle
mêle tous ces faits le fou et ça ça a
marché
j'ai juste meetic quoi ça sert alors
après tu as fait des petits boulots ou
infectées dans l'édition musicale à new
york
au matin de paris et a été l'heureux dit
coluche c'est vrai ça oui c'est vrai
comment ça s'est passé
c'est ca c'est assez rare parce que
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui avait pas
moi dire qu'ils avaient du coeur toute
la france le 10 mai il était à ses
copains et mon beau père un jour des
faits il a fait mon père l'a dit si tu
as du boulot pour mon monde
ça serait bien qu'ils prennent et les
copains qui ce jour mais t'inquiète pas
et lui l'appelle deux jours après il a
fait des sites web en devenir
j'ai été supporter les gens parlaient
lesquels je mettais un micro et j'ai
passé huit mois on a fait toutes les
lignes de france avec les meilleurs
restaurants et c'est très très très bien
c'est là que tu as vu quand on est qu'au
lieu les services tout de suite quoi tu
as compris il fallait être star c'est ça
c'est vraiment c'est exactement ça tu
tires quel bilan de ta carrière
aujourd'hui très sincèrement j'en fais
je sais pas du tout de démagogie
je suis je me trouve un acteur pas mal
pas génial je pense que j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup de travail
c'est comme sur les bulletins scolaires
de mieux faire mais bonne volonté le
rôle que tu rêves devenir kramer contre
kramer ouais un papa avec sa petite
fille je lai dans le film de de pauw
lellouche
mais j'ai envie de peut-être d'en faire
un peu plus et je jouerai volontiers
j'aimerais bien faire un bond à oui moi
j'aime bien les films d'action mais
j'aimerais bien me balader avec un
pétard et tu fais du sport beaucoup je
fais les baraques et non je fais tente
j'ai pas entendu footing chalet du
tennis j'ai fait quand j'étais jeune
quand j'étais jeune j'ai fait avant du
hockey sur gazon et la natation
ah ouais tu bois l'alcool très jeune et
aucune accoutumance arrive t il mais pas
le col et non mais je peux boire de 4
vodka temps j'ai envie de les boire et
quand je suis bien avec des gens et je
peux boire du perrier pendant dix jours
attali dix soirées pas boire ça va
déchirer les cigarettes sépare le bon
quand même c'était dur oui oui j'aime
pas les light jet dé principale est
celle qui te de rapidement qu'en faire
alors dis-moi la drogue
non après la les drogues dures j'ai mené
ma vie n'a jamais pris de la cocaïne et
mériterait il faut pas parce que je
crois que j'en prends tellement je suis
critique mais j'ai fumé
des joints ouais quand j'étais pour la
négative oui j'ai vu un jour très très
bon avec des joints oui j'ai eu c'est ma
réalité mal région non j'ai mal réagi
j'étais vraiment à bien gérer la
religion je ne suis pas un fou je ne
pratique pas drôle du tout mais voyons
pas mais je ne sais pas je suis comme je
suis pas mes enfants quand j'ai envie de
faire un fini d'en entendre du film
voilà je suis content à la douane
voilà je suis partie stratégique ça et
quand ça marche tu divertir
non je n'ai pas merci mais j'ai repensé
à se poser quand même moyen la politique
la politique
oui je me suis intéressé oui maintenant
parce que pendant ce moment ça choquant
que ça ouais c'est pas en france ça se
passe c'est en fait un vrai c'est leur
match chef est bouché tout ça mais au
moment des élections rejoint trsb j'ai
voté c'est un discret devant les banques
et non c'est pas indiscret j'ai voté je
suis on est on doit être trois jeunes
acteurs j'ai voté chirac c'était pas
très copain avec claude chirac la fille
oui mais ça n'a rien à voir
attendez vous avec l'au delà
arru d'entrée on y va vraiment là c'est
fini avant oui j'ai fait sa percée dans
ta vie en commun non bon comité
d'accueil vincent lindon
[Applaudissements]
pour connaître connaître qui vient pas
souvent alors continuons lui fait la
fête à 20 cents c'est alors un moment
quand tu attends bah oui en tout cas
merci d'avoir choisi tout le monde en
parle pour parler de votre nouveau film
d'autant plus que c'est un film
important pour vous c'est une question
là lance pas une question c'est une
constatation c'est important pour vous
c'est un film d'étienne chatiliez qui
s'appelle la confiance règne avec vous
cécile de france eric berger et anne
brochet alors je fais le pitch aller le
pitch une aventure de deux domestiques
cécile de france et vous deux primaires
voire de primates de neuneu deux idiots
deux crétins quoi qui bosse chez des
bourgeois et qui se casse en courant en
piquant ce qu'ils peuvent emporter voilà
ça c'est leur vie quotidienne
mais au-delà de ça ils s'aiment et nous
spectateurs ont fini par les haies mais
voilà c'est des animaux mais ils sont
plus humains que nous des fois un peu
comme la bataille et fontaine c'est oui
c'est un peu ça c'est cdc ils sont ils
sont proches de l'animalité
mais derrière il ya une grosse humanité
ils sont très libres voilà ils font ils
font ce qu'ils disent ils disent qu'ils
font ils y pensent ils disent ils disent
qu'ils pensent ils ont des rapports de
couple entre que à mon avis peu de gens
on ne tombe pas leur langue sept fois
dans la bouche avant de parler
et rien n'est vrai méditer ils font
quand ils volent ils décident pas de
voler c'est parce que ça marche a vu
comme c'est instinctif il voit un truc
le fonctionnent par réflexe absolument
alors il ya un autre pitch on pourrait
dire aussi que ces deux descendants des
groseilles qui sentent domestique chez
les le quesnoy voilà c'est peu si on
veut faire référence aux grands succès
de chatouiller la vie est un long fleuve
tranquille on pourrait dire ça comme ça
pendant un châtaignier
ça dépend avant tout à l'heure j'ai dit
chatiliez l'asie chatellier gentili et
les gens chez eux choisissent cissé
chatillez vous tapez 1 et 6 échappés y
ajoutera pwc
alors rappelant que
par l'anru dire les appels sont surtaxés
la confiance règne parce qu'avant de se
rencontrer il ne faisait confiance à
personne et maintenant ils s'aiment et
la confiance règne en fait c'est là que
ça vient oui enfin c'est l'expression
c'est quand on dit la confiance règne
c'est que justement elle règne pas c'est
comme quelqu'un m'a dit on m'a raconté
un truc l'autre jour j'ai trouvé
vachement bien une expression c'est
quand il ya un doute il ya pas de doute
mais c'est à peu près la même chose une
antiphrase voilà c'est une antiphrase
bien là c'est ça non mais ça c'est un
sera coupé c'est un truc de deux non non
ceci dès qu'on fait un point de
retourner à la la mais non c'est quand
tu dis des trucs intelligents je découpe
pas systématiquement alors vous êtes né
le 15 juillet à 50,9 à boulogne quels
souvenirs vous avez de votre naissance
vincent
alors vint cendres dans le film elle
elle ne domine un elle le trompe
d'ailleurs le lui dit et cette phrase
formidable et lui dit c'est pas parce
qu'on travaille ensemble on dort
ensemble qu'on baise ensemble qu'on est
ensemble ouais elle est marrante salles
énormes et lui c'est un peu on peut dire
débile léger quoi c'est un débit les
gestes et expressions médical très
exactement que cci les lits bête c'est
c'est pas un crétin cci les
et impulsif et c'est quand le niveau de
l'intelligence réagi à la vue ouais
c'est quand on ne pense à rien avant de
faire les choses et qu'on ne pense rien
après les avoir fait c'est quand on les
pense au moment présent
j'ai tout à fait un signe spéculateurs
telle est une espèce de bourvil tu vois
ce que je veux dire
je me rappelle et moi il me fait penser
à nino manfredi dont nous nous sommes
tentés mais de deux d'ettore scola et
n'aurait pas dit non c'est non mais
c'est vrai il ya un côté nino manfredi
pour pour vous c'est extraordinaire
c'est un rôle difficile quand même c'est
une mise en danger extraordinaire non
ouais c'est un rôle difficile mais en
même temps plus je suis assez inquiet
parce que chaque fois que je sais à sam
est assez difficile de voir des extraits
ou de voir le film comme on un acteur on
dit qu'il est souvent à l'écran en tout
cas 50% ce qui lie à la ville il ya
forcément des choses de moi qui sont
dans ce rôle oui donc c'est assez
effrayant que vous êtes passés de
l'autre côté de l'écran là cette fois
non vous faites plus attention à rien
quand on voit votre gueule sur les
affiches on se dit lassé il a pété a
gardé des séquelles de temps attends je
vais d'abord raison la tyrie parce qu'il
marchera les immenses hervé mesures
prendre après je m'occupe de toi eux non
c'est très gentil mais c'est vrai que un
rôle comme ça la question je me suis
posé le travail que j'ai essayé de faire
c'est qu'il faut l'incarner si c'est
pour essayer de marquer une distance d'à
voir ce qu'on appelle c'est ce petit
message subliminal avec la salle en
voulant expliquer chaque fois qu'on joue
que soit moi vincent je suis plus
intelligent que le personnage et que
j'en pense pas moins c'est pas la peine
de le faire plusieurs essais comme au
tennis si vous attaquez pas la balle
celle qui vous attaque si on n'attaque
pas un rôle et qu'on rentre pas dedans
c'est lui qui vous submerge
donc ce rôle là le gros travail c'était
d'accepter ne serait-ce que la fiche
bon je suis dans tout paris avec une
tête ingérable que vous auriez pu vous y
opposer la fiche dans oui j'aurais pu
mais ça aurait été idiot way saurait
s'arrêter sans était une mauvaise idée
il aurait fallu pas faire le rôle même
pas vraiment où je fais le rôle tous en
suisse pour faire un débile léger en
même temps le choix et la main armée
bien
alors donc chatiliez aller facile si
elle ne fait pas de mal an plus tard
chatilla je ne comprends pas 1
celle ci est la vie vincent est un
acteur qui s'impliquent énormément qui
d'une précision époustouflante
alors c'est important quand même pour
vous cette reconnaissance
professionnelle parce que vous aviez
quand même une revanche à prendre sur la
vie parce que vous avez une famille
extrêmement brillante vincent lindon est
toujours vous êtes senti un petit peu
dans votre adolescence en position
d'infériorité
vous avez un petit peu le syndrome
michel drucker sac à michel drucker
c'est quelqu'un qui a eu une famille
très brillante son père médecin à ses
frères qui ont fait des grandes écoles
et tout et lui il avait besoin de
prouver que que voilà qu'il était
vachement bien aussi le prouve encore
tous les dimanches
alors j'ai une famille haut de gamme
alors votre père sur la famille de
l'inde aura votre père laurent
industrielle dans les autoradios il a il
a gagné beaucoup d'argent après il s'est
retiré dans le berry votre mère alix du
fort rebond la connais bien c'est une
grande journaliste qui était à
marie-claire descendante d'un ministre
de la troisième république
ensuite elle a épousé pierre bénichou
directeur oulémas 900 matches donc voilà
ça a quand même pierre bénichou d'orge
conseil la pièce de laurent ruquier dans
laquelle ils jugent pas si vous l'avez
vu oui c'est vrai le grosse chaleur est
excellent en cas d'élection donc ça
c'est votre beau père pierre bénichou
votre grand-père basse et c'est raymond
raymond radon haut magistrat à la cour
de cassation
l'arrière grand mère paternelle c'est la
soeur c'est la soeur d'andré citroën va
rien votre oncle jérôme éditions de
minuit
éditeur de robbe grillet du nouveau
roman vous avez lu les mémoires de la
femme de robbe grillet là n'ont qu'à la
femme de robbe grillet sort ses mémoires
et elle raconte dans ses mémoires que
sont marie robbe grillet donc il va
bientôt rentrer à l'académie quand il
était jeune il avait des moeurs un peu
libre quoi donc il l'a prêté à des
copains il faisait des plans à trois et
c est ce qu on apprend en lisant le
bouquin je vous le dis c'est que votre
oncle jérôme il en croquer c'est à dire
que jérôme lindon le patron des éditions
de minuit beckham l'un des plus grands
éditeurs français un des plus sérieux il
se tapait la femme de robbe grillet ses
yeux de robbe grillet mais c'est ça que
j'aime pas avec le journalisme c'est ça
qui m'embête vie mais pas la précision
d'un journaliste non jeu elle sinon
j'adore le fait que vous avez des fiches
incroyablement précis c'est la première
fois qu'on ne se trompe jamais
d'habitude on dit que jérôme et mon père
ceci que cela mais ça fait penser à une
histoire de jack nicholson qui vit dans
la presse qu'il avait appris au festival
de cannes quand il avait fait easy rider
et que tout d'un coup il est devenu une
star il a appris que sa soeur était sa
mère et que sa mère et sa grand-mère et
là je viens d'apprendre non même que mon
oncle donc en croquer avec la femme
noire oubliée voilà j'aurais dû m'en
passer mais bon je le sais mais voilà
donc ça m'allait bien je le savais pas
mais quand on connaît jérôme lindon qui
est quand même très respectable et tout
savoir qu'ils aient des plans à trois
accros briller sa femme c'est quand même
fort non c'est faux voilà alors comme ça
c'était le ton temps mais comme j'ai dis
quand même famille assez haut de gamme
quand même chez les ch et les lindon a
vraiment et puis des études courtes ce
qui n'est pas le cas dans ce genre de
famille alors vous avez fait un bac
c'est bon ensuite je sais pas trop faire
un accès prépa sup de co vous restez 22
jours
quand même pas le bout du monde non plus
jérôme bon et vincent parsemant la cameg
qui regardent la télévision mbc dans
toutes les librairies j'y peux rien
c'est le bouquin il est sorti ça
maintenant c'est fait c'était la galère
est lui surtout car il ya la socialité
parc on va le savoir plus
donc après au bout de 22 jours de sup de
co vous plaquer vos études pour devenir
être costumier vous avez commencé en bas
être costumier sur le tournage de mon
oncle d'amérique
en fait vous étiez chauffeur de la
camionnette de costumes des jarres
depardieu en 81 pierre bénichou votre
beau-père vous trouve un job d'euros 10
sur la tournée de coluche ça a duré 9
mois puis après vous partez aux usa vous
la chance de voir de la famille un oncle
producteur de musique à new york une
ferme dans le texas vous rentrez en
france le travail au matin de paris
toujours rachel bénichou s'est pas
beaucoup de pistes ont quand même
instant ouais pas mal nommé patrice evra
dans le cinéma l'a effectivement ça doit
rien à personne quoi c'est vous quoi le
premier film mais le faucon paul
boujenah avec huster
ouais c'est moi tout seul et oui c'est
une coïncidence c'est pas vraiment moi
en plus c'est un peu de la chance c'est
parce qu'il est arrivé au cours florent
et il a demandé où était francis huster
je les prie immédiatement pour elie
chouraqui
s'il a fait très plaisir et qu' il est
surtout resté en arrêt devant moi ce
qu'il a trouvé que j'avais énormément de
tic
mais avant qu'on en parle
reçoivent une vanne de l'an aujourd'hui
il faut savoir que j'en ai que deux ou
trois à la minute également j'en avais 5
à 6000
j'en ai beaucoup plaint la minute oui
donc c'était étonnant quoi il est rentré
il a vu un type qui bouge et la tête
comme un fou et il s'est dit jeudi la
demande à israël a dit kikis et qui est
ce mec dans dans le rhin dans le couloir
du coup j'ai été le voir un casting et
je suis tombé en phase 2 du ii d'un
copain de mystère qui s'appelle yves
lemoigne et qui lui aussi à l'éthique et
donc je suis trop en face de lui dans le
bureau et il a cru je me retiens de lui
c'est chamakh il a choisi comme ça c'est
vrai que ça passait et donc il a il
s'est énervé il l'a très mal pris il m'a
viré du bureau 1 et j'ai passé une demi
heure a expliqué donc ce qui est quand
même le comble jeudi mais non je suis
aussi anormal que toi je suis j'ai
génétique je suis malade ce qui nous a
approchés et donc j'ai fait le film et
c'est ma fille allait mettre qu'on est
ici c'est des francs-maçons tue ses
inventions se reconnaissent et c'est
pourquoi il a des tic
c'est depuis le divorce de ses parents
ah ouais ouais c'est quand laurent alix
se sont séparés que julio est d'ailleurs
d'aller voir il faut pas aller voir un
psy pour venir ici toutes les semaines
non mais c'est 80 euros quand même comme
un héros quand même je reviens pas en
paix bah ouais non c'est ça ne savais
pas que ça va aller mieux alors il faut
qu'ils me voilà qui fait éclater en
sanglots là tu veux prendre le temps de
pleurer
non non on enchaîne alors voilà donc
condamnés non mais là on va pas raconter
la suite tout le monde la connaît la
grande carrière de vincent lindon au
cinéma l'engrenage la drogue la voilà
les filles les filles aussi
les filles aussi vous avez défi quand
même très célèbre vincent lindon à
caroline de monaco c'est parti quoi bah
oui alors il boite on en parle
maintenant desquels prochaine je vais
vous dire moi j'aurais eu une aventure
et caroline de monaco j'ai servi je veux
pas qu'on en parle en bien sûr mais là
j'ai dit voilà c'est parti
voilà karaj à monaco à l'appoint tout
chirac c'est vrai mais c'est pas vrai
chirac
non laurent et puissant de rien et qui a
été votre épouse les amours pardon
excusez moi bah oui bah rappel chez pas
peut-être maintenant assez barré
non mais je suis désolé je pensais déjà
pas les zones et tout va bien j'ai fait
une gaffe là pas du tout j'ai l'air
d'être désolé non non non regarde moi
non mais tout va bien comme votre film
s'appelle la confiance règne
on va faire une interview la confiance
règne est ce que vous faites confiance à
votre copine quand elle est seule en
soirée oui dans tous les cas dans tous
les cas parce que tant pis pour elle
c'est son problème
est ce que vous faites confiance à
gérard darmon pour pas draguer votre
copine oui j'y réfléchirai non mais
c'est parce que j'ai des goûts fait
confiance quand une fille vous dit
qu'elle n'a jamais vu un mec comme vous
a si bien c'est une bonne question ça en
plus j'ai envie en tout cas vrai oui
ouais bah oui ça m'arrange vous faites
confiance à votre maman quand elle vous
dit que vous êtes formidable non ouais
je fais confiance à un nom sauf quand
elle me dit qu'elle me trouvant vidame
très bien fait confiance à raffarin pour
sortir le pays de la crise n'ont fait
confiance à l'information du journal de
20 heures de tf1
bah oui enfin cesser c'est ce qu'on
appelle des omeyyades et aux missions
donc je fais confiance dans ce qu'on me
dit mais j'ai pas confiance dans tout ce
qu'on me dit pas fait confiance et la
star academy pour trouver les chanteurs
de demain n'ont fait qu'enfoncer un
journaliste qui vous promet bien entendu
tout ça c'est off vincent oui j'ai envie
me situer le même problème c'est que je
pars du principe que c'est son problème
c'est tant pis pour lui il sentira plus
mal de s'apercevoir qui m'a trahi que
moine apercevoir que je me suis fait
trahir c'est pas un problème je
m'arrange avec ça moi c'est plutôt
perdant de vivre avec l'idée qu'on a
fait quelque chose et qu'on n'a pas tenu
sa parole que tu as fait soi-même bruges
est d'accord je pense que l'honnêteté la
meilleure des combines mais je te trouve
plus jeunes qu'il ya quelques années
autant un peu comme tout le monde j'ai
j'ai mûri comme tout le monde cédric et
reese et je me suis drogué risée pas que
ça qui sait alors il fait confiance a
vaincu de bohème quand ils vous
proposent une partie de poker juste pour
s'amuser
oui j'ai encore fait consentie à deux
jours et alors vous avez perdu combien
non j'ai gagné à met lui aussi à dakar
vous ai trouvé deux pigeons voilà nous
faire confiance à la police quand elle
vous dit qu'elle est là pour vous
protéger mais elle vous dit jamais ça la
police elle vous attrape mais quand elle
est là pour protéger l est pas là vous
faites confiance aux hommes pour qu'un
jour la paix soit enfin possible dans ce
monde c'est pas les hommes qui vont y
arriver ça va hein monsieur condé 3
surtout déjà la nuit là il ait déjà plus
déjà plus un ouais ouais je dis pas que
des conneries non car on le pense que tu
fais des conneries
merci vincent non mais c'est vrai gentil
tu as beaucoup de talent non mais c'est
même pour ça qu'on con qu'on supporte
quoi c'est bien c'est ccc jamais bête
bien sûr pourquoi tu veux partir après
parce que j'aime bien venir une émission
et après partir je n'aime pas rester des
heures fait serait sympa pour dechavanne
et pas mal de temps je veux dire bonjour
quand même et je vais pas rester parce
que je je je pars en je fais attention à
moi je me regarde je suis filmé tout ça
me fatigue
ce que j'aime bien dans la vie au départ
c'est me faire du bien quoi enfin pu
très longtemps mais j'aime bien et dans
un endroit où je vous dis ça me va donc
ça ne va plus de partir que de rester
devant à partir
nous avons pas mal à ma fille est ce que
vous faites confiance à un mec qui vous
propose du shit dans une boîte non
dap d'abord jeanjean prend plus mais non
ça c'est un truc que je n'ai pas
confiance parce que j'ai ce syndrome
j'ai toujours j'ai pas confiance quand
on m'offre quelque chose à manger ou à
fumer dans un endroit bizarre de
quelqu'un que je connais pas parce que
j'ai tellement peur de partir dans un
flip atroce ce dragon mais mis un truc
surtout donc ça ne mangeait pas
confiance ben oui [ __ ] je le crois je le
prends puis je sais ça vous arrive est
déjà un monde en crise
non mais j'ai même pas confiance avec
les cadeaux j'aimerais savoir des petits
cadeaux de de fans ou être une petite
peluche groupe h où ça me me je ne sais
pas d'où ça vient je alors que quand il
marchait boucheron relais cela tu as
confiance l'a déjà plus non mais j'ai un
problème est que qui apporte écoivres
j'aime bien des trucs 9 presque vous
fait confiance
est-ce que je me fais confiance oui
alors là j'ai une théorie qui est très
simple je vais essayer d'expliquer très
rapidement si par hasard on décide que
je dois traverser une rive et qu'on met
une pierre par exemple un caillou la
radio locale s'est passé passé pas mal
au milieu et il rit on met une pierre
toutes les trois mètres et l'écartement
de mes jambes et de deux mètre 80 je ne
suis pas sûr de moi je ne sais pas
comment je vais aller d'une pierre à
l'autre mais le problème d'aller de
l'autre côté de la rive nous ne pose
aucun souci je sais que je vais y aller
donc j'ai assez confiance en moi je ne
suis pas sûr de moi ce qui n'est pas du
tout la même chose
je vous dis je vais à peu près arrivé
vers une zone à 15 mètres près de là où
je voulais aller
[Rires]
[Musique]
la confiance règne chez eux
vous n'avez trouvé comment cette
interview vincent très agréable ça
allait non moi je suis content d'être
venu sur sandrine suis un peu désolé bon
vous pouvez oui c'est la bourde ouais
t'as pas envie de rester un peu je vais
rester pour accueillir christophe non
mais après acquis après christophe après
il ya la main qu eux vas-y barre toi
[Musique]